on est là pour continuer l'organisation
des neuvième jour des îles qui vont se
dérouler à la Réunion en 2015 donc
c'était les représentants des 7 îles
participantes où on a statué sur un
certain nombre de points pour monter en
puissance dans cette organisation on
dirait que la nouvelle décision c'est
qu'on est sûr qu'on n'aura pas plus de
2000 personnes puisque on a un problème
d'hébergement au-delà de cela c'est une
bonne nouvelle pas une mauvaise pour
l'organisation c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce qu'on avait quelques craintes
puisqu'on n'avait pas déjà le retour des
différentes délégations et on se disait
si chacun augmente et participe pas tout
on ne pourra pas tenir donc il faudra le
faire donc ça on s'est mis d'accord
maintenant au 28 juillet on aura le
détail par discipline dans ces
différentes territoires ce qui pourra
donner aux League la possibilité de
mettre en place l'organisation pour les
rencontres et également ce qui a eu
comme décision c'est que on a confirmé à
aux Comores la mise en place des jeux de
2019 sous réserve dans une commission
qui se rendra en mars 2015 sur le
territoire des Comores pour voir où s'en
est pour l'organisation et comme notre
prochaine réunion du qui j'ai prévu le
13 et 14 mai à ce moment-là nous
pourrons statuer d'une manière
définitivement sur la communication de
des jeux puisque certains nous
questionnent certains pensaient même que
les jeux allaient se tenir cette année
au mois d'août non un logo un nime ça va
permettre de visualiser et d'entendre
une musique que j'espère les gens vont
retenir en se disant sa team je me
rappelle ça va être c'est l'une des jeux
de 2015 à la Réunion